the halo tv show may have made some
changes from the games and other lore
but gamers still saw plenty to recognize
from the cheap's heads up display to the
voice of cortana to some sleeping
sitting duck grunts these are all the
small details you may have missed
the third episode of halo titled
emergence begins in a flashback on the
planet obon which is described in a
caption as a ueg tier 2 waste salvage
colony the planet is portrayed as a
hellish wasteland of trash piles and
smog where lower class humans are forced
into brutal slave labor by agents of the
united earth government while this
particular characterization of obama's
new the planet's name is pulled directly
from halo 4. in the wake of the first
human covenant war which ends in halo 3
obon became a primary hub for resettling
human refugees unlike the obon shown in
the halo tv series the planet in the
video games is lush and ecologically
similar to earth unfortunately the peace
on obon is ultimately shattered by an
attack from the covenant remnant forces
the obon scenes also show covenant
elites carrying a device that they refer
to as a luminary which is used to locate
forerunner artifacts while the design
differs a bit in the show luminaries are
indeed a part of the covenant's arsenal
in the halo games
much of halo episode 3 is devoted to the
creation of and early operations of
cortana the ai created by dr catherine
halsey to be master chief stalwart
companion fans of the games will already
be intimately familiar with cortana but
they may not all be familiar with the
process that led to her creation the
halo series stays pretty loyal to the
original canon when it comes to
cortana's origins a process that
revolves around the illegal practice of
flash cloning just like in the show the
halo books detail flash cloning as a
method of rapidly growing human organs
from dna samples the process can also be
used to clone an entire human as halsey
does in violation of ueg law
in both the series and the games she
uses a digitized version of her own
cloned brain as a basis for the cortana
construct but that's not where the
cortana easter eggs stop
jen taylor the voice actor who plays
cortana in the halo video games returns
to voicer in the paramount plus series
as well die hard fans may recognize the
first phrase shutters upon materializing
when the game is over the king and the
pawn go back into the same box
the line is a translation of an old
italian proverb that's associated with
dr halsey's mother in the books and
games something she said to her daughter
while teaching her to play chess it's
cortana's first spoken phrase in the
original canon so it's only right that
it fills the same role in the paramount
plus series
technically though this isn't the first
famous cortana line uttered in the halo
show episode 1 contact includes one of
the character's best remembered and most
heavily memed quotes from the first halo
game this cave is not a natural
formation in the game cortana makes the
statement about a forerunner structure
that is really obviously not natural
in the series the line is spoken by one
of the silver team spartans when they
discover the 4runner artifacts being
excavated on madrigal
in response to the unsc acquiring the
forerunner keystone from madrigal the
covenant prophets send an agent of their
own to take it back mckee the human
reclaimer who defected from the ueg
after witnessing their immense cruelty
she takes a covenant corvette and sneaks
aboard an unsuspecting unsc ship by
using a fake distress call but she isn't
alone when she boards the vessel she's
accompanied by one of the covenant's
most dangerous assets the legolo let
golow are massive alien worms capable of
combining with one another to form
hivemind-esque superbeans in halo video
games they most commonly appear in a
form that the unsc calls hunters hunters
appear to be independent bipedal
warriors but in reality they are simply
massive suits of power armor inhabited
and controlled by small colonies of golo
mckee takes over the unsc gladius with a
swarm of unarmored legolo who quickly
overwhelm all human forces stationed on
the spacecraft before she boards however
there is a brief shot of a proper hunter
from behind only one leg and part of its
weaponized arm are visible but the shot
effectively sets up the arrival of the
hunters into the live-action halo world
though mckee makes short work of the
unsc gladius crew she isn't quite quick
enough to stop the ship's captain from
wiping all sensitive records from the
computer system just before she kills
him with her tiny energy fingernail he
tells the ship to activate the coal
protocol a phrase any fan of the halo
novels will be familiar with as it's the
title of one of the series most famous
books the cold protocol named for unsc
admiral preston coal is a directive
meant to keep the location of earth and
all related information out of the hands
of the covenant by invoking it before
his death the captain of the gladius
blocks mckee from accessing any truly
sensitive data from the ship the show
even goes so far as to include the cold
protocol's exact ordinance number on the
gladius computer screen emergency
priority order 09831a-1
it's a fun little detail that shows just
how much the series writers have paid
attention to the source material
the halo show is clear from the get-go
that the unsc is an authoritarian
military power which dips dangerously
close to outright fascism on many
occasions the organization's higher-ups
have no qualms about killing innocents
abducting children or conducting all
other manner of reprehensible deeds in
the name of order and dominance the unsc
facilities on reach include several
phrases plastered around the walls that
reflect humanity's military-centric
society some of which were pulled
directly from previous halo media one
such phrase appears behind dr halsey
while she's conducting experiments on
the forerunner keystone the phrase
together we prevail these words are part
of a famous poem in the original halo
canon called forward unto dawn which is
also the namesake of a unsc ship in halo
3.
last but not least forward unto dawn is
also the name of the live-action
mini-series produced during the lead-up
to the release of halo 4. another
reference to prior halo media and the
reach facilities appears in the silver
team barracks the phrase paramare
periteris perconstallatum translated it
reads by sea by land by the stars in the
original canon this is one of the chief
mottos of the unsc
the third episode of halo references a
number of locations from the original
series two of these illusions come in a
scene on the rubble in which sauron's
son shows kwan the gas giant hessian and
its smaller moon metaset
but no one goes there
i don't think there's any air
both of these celestial bodies are tied
to the rubble in the halo novels where
metaset's inhospitable atmosphere ends
up causing some serious problems for
humanity a covenant faction uses the
atmospheric conditions of the moon to
quickly grow an attack force of grunts
at the end of episode 3 there's also a
major reference to the planet eridanus 2
master chief's home world i saw it as a
child
on a writtenness too
this is consistent with the lore of the
games and the novels but the nature of
the planet seems to have been changed
significantly originally eridanus 2 was
a thriving and heavily populated world
with several major urban centers in the
show it's changed to be a colony world
wiped clean of human habitation by a
deadly plague
the halo show explores one of the darker
aspects of the franchise's lore how most
of the candidates for the unsc spartan 2
program were kidnapped as children on dr
halsey's orders after interacting with
the forerunner keystone master chief
begins to have flashbacks to his
childhood in episode 4 he's shown as a
boy being trained by the unsc and
conditioned by halsey in the original
halo lore abduction was also the means
to which halsey recruited her spartans
she used genetic data gathered from
humanity's various interstellar colonies
and analyzed the physical and mental
aptitude of her candidates to determine
which children would be the best
possible subjects for her experiments
she then kidnapped them and replaced
them with flash clones whose bodies
would quickly break down the kids
themselves had no say in the matter they
and their families suffered immense
trauma as a result of the operation and
dr halsey's method seemed to reflect a
belief in eugenics to top it all off the
spartan 2 program wasn't even originally
conceived to battle the covenant in the
original lore halsey proposed the
initiative to efficiently quell human
rebellions and insurrections in the
unsc's outer colonies
from the moment soren is introduced in
halo tv series he starts dropping
references to his origins in the halo
evolution short story collection while
the character has changed in many ways
from his equivalent in the book he
shares the same basic story of defecting
from the spartan 2 program and being
pursued relentlessly by the unsc as a
result in halo episode 4 sorin reveals
another way in which he pulls from his
evolution story his tragic and violent
relationship with his father
in the evolution story pariah which
details soren's life he's raised on an
outer colony world called dwarka by his
mother and stepfather his mother grows
ill from a local disease but his
stepfather is negligent in her care and
refuses to take her into town for
treatment until it's too late when sora
discovers his mother's dead body which
is hidden from him at first by his
stepfather he swears revenge and
attempts to kill his stepfather with a
knife since he's still young at the time
the attack fails to kill the man so
sorin instead waits in the forest around
their farm until the sickness that took
his mother takes his stepfather as well
from what's said in the paramount plus
show it's unclear how close sorin's new
story is to pariah all he says to quan
in episode 4 is that it took him a year
after his defection to remember that his
father was dead and another year after
that to remember that he killed him
regardless of the details though the
halo show is clearly taking some
inspiration from pariah when it comes to
soren's past
the warthog is unquestionably the most
recognizable of all the halo vehicles
having appeared in one form or another
in every game in the franchise the most
common model of warthog is a minigun
mounted in the bed which a standing
marine can operate independently of the
driver in halo episode 4 another version
of the warthog is shown one that
features an expanded crew bed instead of
a mounted weapon master chief halsey and
her assistant used the vehicle during
the expedition to a readiness 2 where
they search for 4runner artifacts from
john's past this larger less combat
oriented warthog is drivable in various
halo games and it's one of many less
common variants one of the best things
about the paramount plus series is its
loyalty to the games in terms of visual
design for weapons vehicles and gear and
that stays true with the various
warthogs seen in halo
during a conversation with miranda keys
in episode 4 kai 125 invokes the name of
preston cole a pivotal figure from the
halo novels
from the age of six i studied military
strategy from sun zoo to preston coal
coal is referenced earlier when the coal
protocol a directive to keep the
location of earth from the covenant at
all costs is mentioned but it's a nice
touch for those who've read the books to
hear the admiral's full name cole's life
is explored in detail through various
halo books and comics including one of
the primary stories in halo evolutions
the novel halo the fall of reach and the
book that bears his name halo the cole
protocol
born on earth cole was a major figure in
the unsc's battles with pirates and
insurrectionists in the outer colonies
later he became the most decorated
officer in the war against the covenant
earning multiple victories including one
at the battle of harvest the first human
planet conquered by the invaders though
cole was believed to have been killed
during a particularly dangerous campaign
the lore leaves things open-ended and
never confirms his death
one of the memories that comes to master
chief on aridness 2 is of a young dr
halsey playing with him as a boy in his
family's kitchen she gives him a coin
emblazoned with the unsc logos and has
him flip it and guess heads or tails
john displays an almost miraculous
talent for the game guessing correctly
on 11 straight tosses impressed halsey
remarks well aren't you the lucky one a
line that may be a reference to the halo
games though he clearly possesses an
aptitude for combat tactics strategy and
leadership master chief is also
described in the games as being
incredibly lucky this observation is
probably most famously made by cortana
in the opening cut scene of halo 3
during which she delivers a short
monologue about how and why she chose to
be paired with john you had something
they didn't something no one saw but me
can you guess
luck
of course in halo show cortana doesn't
get to choose her spartan she's paired
with master chief by dr halsey still
it's nice to see the series paying some
form of tribute to jon's infamous luck
in halo episode 4 miranda keys takes the
members of silver team excluding master
chief into a lab where she analyzes
covenant weapons and technology
the scene is filled with several easter
eggs and references to the games there
are multiple covenant firearms on
display including a type 51 carbine and
a needler which kai 125 picks up
excitedly and quickly begins explaining
in her discussion of the needler she
drops a couple explicit references to
the games the gun comes from as soon as
the needles hit the target they super
combine and bam
all you see is a big pink mist of blood
and evaporating body fluids
the word super combine is a direct
callback to the games and the mention of
a pink mist is a reference to a
needler-based achievement in halo 3
which itself is a reference to the war
movie jarhead later in the scene as the
spartans help miranda decode the sangili
language kai can also be seen holding a
purple plasma grenade it's one of the
two original grenade types that are
usable in the original halo and it's the
most common such weapon wielded by the
covenant throughout the series there are
a number of other touches from the game
to miranda's lab such as the cadaver
pieces of sangili elites and what appear
to be dormant legolo in a tube the
worm-like creatures that combine to form
the fearsome covenant hunters
halo episode 5 reckoning takes place
almost entirely on master chief's
homeworld of aridness 2 where dr halsey
sets up a temporary camp to examine and
excavate the second 4runner keystone
the main ship in use for the operation
is the unsc pioneer and while it barely
even appears on screen in the paramount
plus show that name is pretty important
in the halo novels in halo the fall of
reach the pioneer is the ship the master
chief and his spartan two compatriots
take on a mission to you guessed it
aridness ii
in the canon of the books the planet and
its surrounding system are a hotbed of
rebel and insurrectionist activity
against the unsc and john and his team
are sent to apprehend a marine defector
operating in the area the tv series
references this rebellious history on
aridness 2 during the flashback when a
woman is showing halsey and captain
jacob keys around the planet's human
colony the colonial insurrection touched
everyone even here on our little out of
the way planet
of course in the canon of the show
aridness 2 is far less central to the
rebellion storyline but it's interesting
to see its original version referenced
by the use of the unsc pioneer halsey
and key's false pretenses for visiting
the planet are also pulled straight from
the old canon where they posed as a
couple to investigate potential spartans
before they ever actually got together
the aridness 2 battle in episode 5
features quite a few covenant species
and ships not previously or only barely
seen before in the series
the large phantom drop ships and smaller
banshee aircraft get a lot more screen
time in reckoning and they're joined by
several other iconic vehicles and
weapons the covenant deploy from their
cruiser via drop pods which are
incredibly faithful to their original
design seen in the games cortana even
refers to the small groups of aliens
held in the pods as lances the game's
term for a squad of covenant soldiers
later a different sort of dropship a
covenant spirit descends from the main
cruiser the distinct two-prong design of
the ship should be instantly familiar to
those who played either the original
halo or halo reach and other variations
of the ship appear across the franchise
it's fun to see the show's creators
pulling inspiration from so many
different corners of the lore especially
when iconic pieces of text such as the
spirit are recreated with such care
prior to halo episode 5 only the cengili
elites the prophets and the let golo are
seen representing the covenant that all
changes during the battle on aridness 2
which sees silver team in the unsc
marines facing off against a platoon of
jackals and grunts in the games these
two species are generally used as lower
level enemies under the command of
larger more tactical covenant officers
however as the halo series demonstrates
they can also be fearsome foes in their
own right for the most part the show
stays pretty close to the grunts and
jackals of the games they still
primarily use needlers and plasma
pistols and their visual design is
generally loyal there are some notable
differences however for instance one of
the jackals is seen dispatching marines
with a smaller version of an energy
sword a weapon typically only used by
elites in the games but there are
instances of jackals wielding similar
weapons in some of the halo books so
it's possible that this is another
reference for die hard fans while grunts
and jackals will never be the most
challenging or exciting enemies in halo
it's fun to see the show diving deeper
into the covenant ranks
as you might expect the halo show makes
a lot of winks and nods to its video
game origins some of these easter eggs
like master chief shield sound effects
and the first person perspective shots
are direct references to mechanics from
the halo games but some of them point to
other popular franchises or moments from
gaming history for instance in halo
episode 1 a voice can be heard over a
unsc loudspeaker saying commander
shepard you are requested at the
skillion response center in the popular
sci-fi game series mass effect commander
shepard is the main character in a
military operation known as the skillion
blitz as a key part of his backstory
during the battle on aridness 2 in halo
episode 5 cortana gives master chief a
good halo gameplay tip switch to
secondary i know how the game is played
this is a clear reference to the
traditional two weapon system used by
many first person shooter games
including halo
most halo games follow a similar pattern
as far as level design goes there's
always a tank level where you drive a
unsc scorpion and often a big warthog
escape sequence during the final chapter
and there's always at least one or two
bigger vehicle based levels halo episode
5 emulates that last archetype in its
climactic battle on a redness in which
master chief drives a warthog through
covenant ranks with his fellow spartans
banning the guns later on chief also
manages to jump onto a low-flying
banshee which he uses to destroy a
phantom drop ship in both cases master
chief effectively hijacks the vehicles
from covenant soldiers he shoots a grunt
out of the driver's seat of the warthog
and he tries his best to disrupt the
flight control of the banshee's pilot
after jumping aboard hijacking vehicles
is a major mechanic in the video games
and it especially comes into play in the
more open levels in multiplayer where
players are constantly jumping from one
motor transport to another
after finding his way through lances of
grunts jackals and banshees in halo
episode 5 master chief looks like he's
about to get the 4runner keystone safely
into the hands of the unsc but just when
it seems that all covenant resistance
has been defeated jon comes face to face
with one of the most dangerous soldiers
in the entire alien army a brute
chieftain
those who played the games will be
intimately familiar with the brutes
ape-like bruisers who serve as
lieutenants and front-line muscle for
the covenant the most dangerous brutes
are classified as chieftains and that
select group wields a range of
particularly powerful weapons in halo
episode 5 the chieftain who confronts
master chief holds the infamous gravity
hammer a massive melee weapon that
creates powerful shock waves each time
it hits the ground
throughout the halo tv show different
members of the covenant are heard
referring to master chief as demon a
nickname also heard in the video games
both the sangili and the prophets on
high charity use that term and mckee
even calls master chief demon to his
face when she finally meets him in
episode six
i'm john
you're the demon
that's what the sangheili called you
in the games chief is referred to as
demon in both cut scenes and combat for
instance when the player successfully
routes a group of grunts during a
firefight they'll often run screaming
about the demon and give up trying to
fight the name is also used by tougher
covenant soldiers like the brutes and
elites though they're usually less
frightened to master chief when they use
it
relax
i'd rather not piss this thing off demon
really the demon nickname is a testament
to how much master chief stands out
compared to the other spartans all of
halsey's soldiers receive the same
augmentations and training but john
rises head and shoulders above the rest
even the covenant themselves recognize
how exceptional he is on the battlefield
which is why they gave him the title of
demon
after conning her way into unsc custody
in halo episode 6 mckee tells master
chief that the covenant will be taking
the second forerunner keystone to a
planet called ross costa which is in the
espero system a sparrow is a name that a
few fans may recognize as it plays a
crucial role in a couple of the halo
novels in the original canon the espero
system is home to the planet hezduros an
old forerunner colony primarily
inhabited by singily in the present-day
timeline more importantly hezeros is
linked via a portal system to the
forerunner shield world of onix the
connection comes into play a couple of
times in the halo books including in
karen travis's halo the thursday war and
matt forback's halo legacy of onyx it
seems that the asparal system of the
live-action halo series is a bit
different roskoska doesn't figure into
the old lore in any major way and since
the character of mckee is brand new for
the show as well it makes sense that the
story is going in a different direction
a brief scene in the middle of halo
episode 6 shows kai entering a munitions
room as her comrades are looking at a
digital image of the m6 spartan laser in
the video games the spartan laser is one
of the most powerful weapons that
players can use but it also comes with a
downside to fire the bright red energy
blast produced by the weapon you must
first charge it for a few seconds this
caveat makes aiming the shot much more
challenging and landing one far more
satisfying the physical design of the
weapon is spot on in the paramount plus
show but the easter egg goes a bit
deeper by also referencing how the
spartan laser works was the discharge
rate on an m6c battery cell 20
right 20 so maximum five shocks
in halo episode 7 inheritance outer
colony mobster an all-around villain
venture grath is heard reciting some
darkly poetic verses about the planet
magical though the fuel harvested from
within the planet has made him a rich
ally to the unsc venture clearly doesn't
hold much love in his heart for the
planet nor for those who fought him to
defend it the poetry recited by venture
is actually pulled directly from the
john milton classic paradise lost and
that specific selection is of special
relevance to the story of halo in the
most literal sense venture's choice of
poem signifies how he views magical as a
hellscape he's been unfairly cast down
into the section he quotes details the
ordeal of satan and the other fallen
angels of heaven who are cast down into
the fires of hell to suffer after
rebelling against god it's curious that
venture would choose to self-identify as
the devil in this instance but maybe
that's just what bad guys do
after returning to madrigal in hopes of
reigniting her father's rebellion kwon
ha journeys deep into the planet's
barren desert and discovers a remote
enclave of mystics she's informed that
the group is connected to her ancestors
and that her father learned important
secrets from them we didn't start with
your father
there were others in your family before
him
in the hopes of following in his
footsteps kwon undergoes a hallucinatory
journey of the mind by ingesting some
mysterious liquid provided by the
mystics
anyone who's read frank herbert's dune
or seen any of the live-action
adaptations will immediately recognize
some inspiration here the classic sci-fi
novel revolves around the remote desert
planet of arrakis which is valued
because of the addictive and
mind-altering spice melange that grows
there many other movies shows video
games and books have pulled elements
from doom and the halo series continues
that tradition
quanta's journey into the magical desert
leads her to a curious and exciting
revelation there's a portal within the
planet that her ancestors have fought to
protect for generations during her
drug-induced dream sequence quan
glimpses a well dug by one of her
forefathers out of which flies a small
robotic being those who play the halo
games will instantly recognize the
creature as a monitor an autonomous
machine created by the forerunners to
oversee and protect their various
installations the most famous monitor in
the halo video games is 343 guilty spark
a deceptive character who at different
points serves as both friend and foe
presumably the monitor scene in the
paramount plus series journeys to
madrigal through the portal within the
planet which may connect it to one of
the halo rings forerunner portals of
this kind also have a precedent in halo
games and books and there have been
multiple instances of important
locations being linked with such
technology
after completing her vision quest quan
has informed that she is a protector
someone called to defend the secrets of
mandrigold the particular word used is
interesting because in the halo games
protector is a subset to the 4runner
sentinel robots that guard the halo
rings and other similar installations
because of the magical portal's
connection to the forerunners this could
be an intentional nod to the games
bringing the humans who guard the portal
under the same banner as the sentinels
themselves either way quan quickly
proves her salts as a protector by
taking down venture graft and a whole
squadron of his men she scores one
particularly gruesome kill in classic
halo fashion by sticking a covenant
plasma grenade to the back of one of her
enemies if we're going to fight
we meet them on my terms
one of the sillier easter eggs of halo
season 1 comes early in episode 8
allegiance when master chief and mckee
go for a walk in the park on reach
while out and about the two stop and
chat in front of an unassuming lemonade
stand the logo on the employee's uniform
and the stand itself advertises goss
lemonade if you played the latter halo
games you may recognize the brand name
halo 5 guardians and halo infinite both
feature references to a fictional canned
drink called goss which uses slogans in
its advertisements like drink like a
spartan and kick your tongue in the face
the name of the drink seems to be a
reference to the goss rifle itself named
for fame physicist carl friedrich goss
which is a commonly seen mounted weapon
on warthogs and halo games
while talking to master chief and
allegiance mckee quotes a bit of an
ancient covenant prophecy pertaining to
the supposed great journey when the
stars sparkle like glass a divine wind
will rush through propelling all those
who are worthy on a great journey to the
sacred ring where we will become like
gods the verse references a brutal
covenant war tactic that comes into play
later in the episode glassing in the
halo games glassine is the term used for
the alien army's genocidal attacks on
planets where powerful energy weapons
are used to melt everything on the
surface shortly after mckee invokes the
term the unsc is brought face to face
with just such an attack the glass
planet is revealed to be none other than
criterion a human colony from the halo
books in the original version of the
story the planet is defended by the unsc
in a full-scale battle unfortunately
criterion isn't so lucky in the tv show
after seeing the decimation wrought by
the covenant on criterion admiral
margaret parangoski urgently request
that someone named admiral whitcomb be
contacted in an effort to launch a
counter-attack though the plan is vetoed
by captain jacob keys those who've read
halo first strike or halo ghost of onyx
may recognize the name admiral danforth
whitcomb is a prominent character in the
first strike novel in particular whereas
many military exploits and successful
missions against a covenant are detailed
wickham was one of the highest ranking
and most decorated officers in the unsc
during the human covenant war and it's
fun to see him getting a little shout
out in the live-action halo show
in the final episode of halo season 1
master chief leads silver team on a
dangerous mission to the covenant's holy
planet where mckee and the prophets are
preparing to unite the two keystones and
signal a path to the halo ring what
follows is an extended action sequence
which begins when chief leads his squad
in an orbital drop from their ship down
to the planet's surface the camera then
jumps to the ground where covenant grunt
is snoozing on guard duty his nap ends
up being the death of him as master
chief crashes into him from the sky
before the grunt can even wake up a
notice in the halo games sleeping grunts
are a common sight many levels feature
whole squads of the little guys napping
frighteningly close to a combat zone
master chief's battle to procure the
4runner keystones in the season 1 finale
of halo pits him and the rest of the
silver team against a mighty covenant
force when the prophets discover the
humans invasion they summon the zealots
a subset of zengili elites that fans of
the games will be well acquainted with
however the zealots of the paramount
plus halo series are quite different
than those found in the source material
historically zealots have been the most
elite of the elites commanders and
leaders equipped with powerful weapons
and armor in fact the ceremonial guard
who performs the keystone ceremony looks
more like those original zealots than
the elites who emerge in hordes to fight
the spartans in addition to the elite
silver team is confronted by a squad of
covenant brutes including the chieftain
who previously fought chief in halo
episode 5. that particular brute still
wields the fearsome gravity hammer as
his weapon of choice but another brute
is shown wielding a spiker a deadly
rapid-fire weapon used by the brutes and
halo games
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]